they are yeah cool it is nice to draw it  is nice to have an opinion using data  however drawing conclusions just based  off data I don't agree so I think it's  hard to have discussions with people  that don't draw any conclusions Based on  data because then it's just how we feel  life is about how you feel though no no  it's the policy is based off of data no  life is about how you feel it's about  you make you make decisions on based on  how you feel right do you think that we  should make policy based on how people  feel um policies policies based on how  people feel yeah yeah going on this  Logic No No I can't lie no okay so it  has to be awesome yeah like backtracking  on my statements so it has to be based  on data correct  give me a second you are ready for this  argument I wasn't